[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar a novel and rapid platform to
generate gram-level antibodies for
diagnostic and therapeutic use
i am matt ashton of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and brought to
you by gen script
to learn more please visit genscript.com
we do encourage you to participate today
by submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation you may also submit any
technical issues here as well if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker hau
tan head of shanghai cell line and virus
vector development department
how you may now begin your presentation
hello everybody uh welcome to this
webinar my name is hau tan and i'm the
head of engineering and birth production
team at jasper i'm very glad to have
this opportunity to give this
presentation today my topic is
a novel and rapid platform to generate
grammar of antibodies for diagnostic and
therapeutic use
as you can see here in this title today
i'm going to talk a lot about antibodies
and protein productions
i think just pre-productions in the
protein science service so i'm also
going to mention a lot about protein
sciences as well
and this is basic background information
so let's get started
uh first let me briefly introduce jasper
transcript is 30 years old this year and
is most famous for its gene synthesis
service
but protein service has also been
established for a long time which is
about 18 years ago and we have very good
track record
and we have also developed one of the
best show platform on the market
and which is also the major topic today
i'm going to talk about
how we develop the system and what it
can offer
in 2002
g-spot was founded in new jersey and in
the same year we launched the first
custom gene synthesis platform and two
years later operating service was
established
and after about 20 years development
fiscal has become
an international corporation
and our protein science group has also
made great achievements in 2021 princess
team has opened a new rnd and production
facility in singapore and i will also
open shanghai side for certain
engineering and virus production
which is
this is where i based
the corporation has four major business
units
including jscrip focusing on labs and
cro
and we also have best enzyme
for industries and production and
electron biotech for cell therapy and a
probiotic for biologic cdmo
and for instance his theme this left
side cro in this part
it also has
other
services like gene synthesis and peptide
synthesis
uh when we talk about protein production
we have to talk about biologics and fad
this is where most of the demands come
from in this part i will first give a
brief introduction and then talk about
the pain points in this area and
offer some common solutions
since this discovery anybody has
revolutionized medicine both
therapeutics and diagnostics
so
when we talk about
biologics in led development mostly we
are talking about antibiotic development
and but it's the most common protein of
therapeutics thanks to its capability of
banning almost any protein biology
serious
so it's easy to develop
and it also it is also much safer
because uh spending is highly specific
there are many formats of antibodies
here we have released some examples
and basically it's harnessing the
highly specific vetting
feature of
of antibodies to design new therapeutics
like by specific antibody and
tri-specific animal
and sometimes it can also be combined
with other molecules
to design new therapeutics such as
antibody drug conjugates
beside the therapeutics anybody has also
been well used
in detection kits especially diagnostic
kit
so
there is a lot of demands for anybody
production
this is a workflow for biologics
discovery development as you can see
here this process is really complicated
includes the basic research for a
clinical development clinical trials and
if lucky enough finally the fda approval
there is a checkpoint here before this
clinic trials which is called ind and
this stands for investigational new drug
before this port before this point no
gmp practice is necessary so i think in
this part most important thing is to
quickly narrow down the candidate and we
can get at least from thousands to
single digit numbers and then move
forward to clinical trials
this whole process
starts from target identification
and
first you need to find the target and
then identify some leads
and then narrow down the candidates
before moving forward to clinical
studies this is a very tight and
cash-consuming process there is a very
popular saying in this field which is to
develop a drug you will need 10 years
and 1 billion dollars
and then here is the workflow for ibd
development everyday search for in
visual diagnostics
these are tests on samples such as blood
or tissue that have been taken from the
human body this is basically
a simplified version of biological
discovery development because
most of the diagnostics
are not used in favor so the regulations
here are much easier and usually in this
whole process gmp practice is not
necessary
and this whole process starts from
target screening and then move forward
to iso development and then i say
validation and optimization and after
all this is done
it goes to the commercialization stage
for either biologics or diagnostics
development there are many demands for
fast and cost effective ground level
antibody production
take biologics as an example at the
pre-ind stage large amount of high
quality proteins are needed
for in vapor toxicity studying animals
usually the amount needed is
0.5 gram to 10 grams
and for ind development because no gmp
practice is necessary
and
at the most stages a lot of items need
to be performed so
for many of the ibd stages ground level
antibody production is needed
there are currently two major solutions
to this demand
but both of them have very obvious
shortcomings the first one is a stable
choice solution in this solution you'll
need to develop
a stable chose cellular or cell pool to
produce a ground level proteins
but the turnaround time here is usually
very long it's usually longer than 10
weeks
and if you have multiple candidates you
will need to
develop multiple
stable pools or stable cell lines so the
cost is going to be very high and the
second solution is transiting hex system
but but most of the biologics are
produced in show systems so we move from
we move forward from play ind to
to to this
clinical trials you need to switch from
hack to true system and there are some
there should be some unknown risks
here in this table it can show a
comparative and i also highlighted two
key features which i think are most
important
the first is that uh i also mentioned in
last slide which is most of the approved
monokuma antibodies are produced in true
system so
oftentimes if you have done the pre-ind
study in hex system you will eventually
need to switch to true system in the
clinical trials
but during the switch
there might be some unknown surprises
and the second key feature is that true
system can be easily scaled up
and the cost can be well controlled
especially for this gram level protein
production and there are also many other
differences between these two systems
and if you're interested you can have a
look
but the key point i want to make here is
that the pre-ind study is very important
uh during this during this design of the
study the the host should also be
considered
in this part i will try to present how
we address this guy in javascript
i think from what we have discussed
before we have already got two clear
goals right
the first thing is the choice of
wholesales
because show sales has been the major
production source for approved biologics
so we have chose true sales
as the host and all we also need to
measure the cost and also shorter the
turnaround tab especially when compared
with a stable short service
and in gscrip we have already developed
this turbo true hp system which is
specifically designed to target the
demands we discussed before but turbo 2
hp is not the only system we have
actually it is a part of our whole new
comprehensive platform so
i'm also going to give you a brief
introduction of other expression systems
and then
give some
case studies
here's the overall scheme for turbotrope
platform development we attack all parts
of protein production including
cells
which means urine and medium and
transfection in and vector and also
production process we also follow this
design build measure learn and rebuild
circle to improve our
system versions by versions
and here i also list the things we have
done here
which is we will first screen conditions
for all parts of buff and then we build
systems with combat optimizations we
also have high throughput measurement
system to measure all these combined
optimizations found out the important
ones
and then we continue the cycle to
constantly improve our troubleshoot
platform and after runs and runs of
optimization our trouble chooses has
become
best in class and then it is released
uh in the following slides i'm gonna
show
the optimization of some key features
this development process the first one
is to pick variable cell density during
protein expression at the first version
the pvcd is less than 10 and after
several rounds of screening and
engineering cells
the cells
pvcd can reach more than 40
10 to the 6 per meal
and
this pvcd is higher than most commercial
available systems
and also our system has been developed
to be more resilient
and
as you can see here in this panel b
combined with optimizing culture process
high cell density can be sustained and
good availability can can be stably
maintained for 16 days or more
and for for most molecular antibodies 16
days of
hydrogen 95 availability can be easily
achieved
but we do observe that we expressing
some antibodies wholesale steps faster
in commercial systems
but
we even
even though that
antibodies non-toxic to host cells
but this issue can be largely relieved
in turbocharged system because this
system is much more
resilient
in this slide i'm going to show some
data examples of vector optimization a
vector plays very important roles in
protein expression
and even a slight difference
in some small components can make a very
big difference
here in this panel b i will give you
example here we
screened for many components and
evaluated its
influence on this
protein production and as you can see
here they act very differently and
some can increase some can enhance the
pattern some can
decrease the tether
so we have chose we have chosen the
enhancer tether enhancing elements and
put them together to redesign new
vectors
and in this panel b this is example of
some intermediate results
we combined
the screen components and put them into
new designs like design tool and design
one as you can see here in panel b
compared to this control design one and
design two have a significant increase
in title
the previous two slides many focused on
title enhancements
and
i do have some data to show you later uh
in the following slides but here i'm
pretty confident to see that our turbo
true system can give you the best yield
available on the market
and but still there are some other
features that are needed for this
protein production system
here therapeutics for cancer is a very
good example
here in this panel b we can see that
there are some mechanisms of actions
of some antibodies some some of them are
just
induced by
simply bending to the receptor like
apoptosis and receptor internalization
and electron bonding emission
but there are some
effector functions that is mediated by
fc region
including this complement-dependent
cytotoxin the antibiotic cellular
cytotoxic and also antibiotic cellular
phycocytosis
for this effect functions
the fc region is needed and also this uh
co-consolation on that fc region is also
very important
and we have also checked uh the approved
therapeutics in cancer therapy as you
can see here in this panel b the adcc
and adcp are common mla in cancer
therapy
cancer therapies
so this
effector functions are very important
for some
specific
specific
therapeutic development
among the effector functions
adcc is especially of interest
cost in cases have shown goods that are
toxic to tumor cells the figure here
shows how adcc works
first antigen on the surface of tumor
cells can be recognized by therapeutic
antibodies with these cdi regions
and its
fc regions can be recognized by mkcl
receptors which is cd16 and then the nk
cells can be activated and then the
cells can kill tumor cells
and since the adcc is so important so
there have been a lot of studies
to
increase the adcc
by therapeutic antibodies from the
perspective of antibody engineering edc
enhancement was usually done by
glycosylation modification or
introducing mutations into fc regions
but as you can see here which is
highlighted in this table
fuel consolation reduction or depletion
is a popular and also of validated
methods
and because there have already been
some drugs that have been approved using
this moa
there is also plenty of data that shows
adcc can be enhanced by field
consolation here is an example i put
here on the left panel in this figure we
have two different groups of samples
in the control sample
the fuel consolation is 94 percent in
the low fuel cost sample the fuel
consolation is nine percent and in the
low fuel cost group the cytotoxic is
more than a two-fold hydrogen control
group
and
so here at g-script we also
developed a 100 vehicle-free system
baseline engineering and cultural
process optimization
the fuel conference overture returned
the high productivity feature and also
removed the fuel consolation from
glidecam profiles to validated that
we
produced the same igg in both turbo true
and fuelco-free turbocharged system and
compared the icon profiles as you can
see here on the right panel
the glidecam profiles
shifted totally
to the right side to the left side which
means
there is no fuel consolation detected in
this figure-free turbocharged system
so with this system
it can hugely benefit the tumors of
therapeutics development
fuel core stipulation can enhance adccc
but adcc is not the only one that can be
objected by car acceleration for example
as you can see here
for those antibody fragments like in fc
region the half lab cdc adcc and adcp
all of them will be reduced
and for anybody's that with no
glycosylation the adcc adcp and cdc will
be reduced
and for most uh
therapeutic antibodies they are igg
subclass and they are called excellated
that is conserved as parisian possession
and 297
and
this is a figure of carbon card
acceleration produced intro system
and this glycosylation can also
affect the half-life of the antibody
here
in this slide i'm going to show you some
mega mechanisms mechanisms behind it
here are the common like forms of
antibodies produced in trouble i listed
two sets of
collect forms here the first one is for
a regular turbocharged system
where it has a
red triangle which represents the fuel
cost
and the other one is this fuel free
turbocharged system and here this rear
triangle is gone which means
this is frugal free
and
there are also some other
glycophones
here is one example of high metals or
glycophone mine five method ratio is
usually low in a given sample but
sometimes it can significantly increase
but methamphetamine is not good for
half-life of antibodies so
here is a piece of data
in this figure panel b and panel c are
the same antibody b does not contain
mag5 c contains my five and the same
color
the same dose it really shows that
half-life is much shorter in my
5-containing group
and it decreases even faster with
decreasing
those in this black group the method
containing group the half-life is even
shorter than fifty percent of this
number five group
besides half-life of anybody mine5 can
also
affect other refactor functions such as
adcc and cdc as you can see here on the
on the left panel
there are some data shows that
high manfred have increased the adcc
function
but regarding cdc the my highman5 has
decreased the cdc function
here at gsc we have also developed
another control protocol
in the with this protocol the 95 percent
ratio can be reduced up to 75 percent
and
in this galactic profile data as i have
highlighted here you can see that this
is my
five can be clearly observed in this
control group but it is nearly invisible
for in this low my valve group
but regarding the other guy conforms
it is nearly unchanged so with this
low mf protocol you can have a very
consistent data with our regular
turbochill system
in all projects we have tested minefire
was well controlled under five percent
so
this uh
this is a very reliable minecraft
control protocol
okay after introducing how we develop
this platform let me show you how this
platform performs i'll give you some
real-world data show some case studies
and then you can have better
understanding what we can offer
but first let's go back to the very
beginning go back to the unmet demands
in biologics and diagnostics development
still remember the two goals we before
we set out to develop our own system
which is the first we need to use show
cells as wholesaler which is more
reliable and then we need to reduce both
the turnaround time and the cost which
can be translated into fast and cost
effective
so the unmet demands was translated into
unbanned needs and are listed here which
is
we need ground level antibody but the
production needs to be fast cost
effective and also reliable
as i mentioned before there are usually
two solutions for this unmanned demands
the first one is hack system the second
one is true staple for service
but both of them have very obvious
economies here i present you this third
solution which is g-script solution
the turbo true hp system the xp stands
for high performance
i'll give you some
key features of this system the first
one is high yield the average expression
is 3.1 gram per liter and we also have
industry experts
which is 24 hour phd level support and
the scale up can also be done in the
central cell
so
this consists the consistency is also
much better
when compared with hexastone we'll use
the chocolate which is more reliable and
there will be million surprises when
transferring to gmp production
and when compared with stable food
service
our
turnaround time is way shorter and the
cost is also larger
here are some data of any reproduction
in hp system
and the samples are different isotypes
of antibodies but the expression level
is very high in all of them average size
is 3.1 gram per liter and we have also
achieved 7 gram per liter in some cases
and the antibody purity is also very
high and
a 95 percent of more purity is easily
achieved
here we have also tested the stability
of this chozella
we test in two ways the first is direct
passaging and the second is pathogen
from car stock
as you can see here
there is nearly no decrease in this
direct passaging way and in this passage
from crosstalk there is only a slight
decrease so we can see that it is the
expression level is quite stable
and
if you want to do this reproduction you
can expect
a consistent expression pattern and also
medium surprises
in the following slides i'm going to
present a few case studies and in this
one we did a benchmarking with
competitors choose stable for surface as
you can find in figure b the purity was
very similar
for all the three samples produced
interval true hp system the purity is 99
or higher
but if you look at the data in figure a
it is very easy to
find out that should turbo true hp
issued more stable performance
both tire wise and tit-wise
let's take anybody one as an example you
can see that the yield of
stable
stable pool is less than 1.5 gram per
liter by in turbo true hp system the
yield is more than 30 gram per liter and
and the turnaround time for stable pool
is about 60 days but for a turbo true hp
system it is about 40 days
and
if you compare
this this data among different samples
the difference is gonna be
huger
and
the longest turnaround time for a stable
pool service
goes up to 120 days
so
just imagine that if the
the delivery is delayed it's delayed and
the animals you prepare the growth tool
for that test
so it's just a waste of money and time
the stability of our hp system can help
you with better project planning
so far we have talked a lot about
regular antibody production
but uh ripple antibodies not the only
molecules that can benefit from this new
system
as uh
by specific antibodies are getting more
and more popularities we also tested a
classic format which is cross map here
and we compared it
in this hp system with a competitive
system in this competitor system after
one step purification with protein a the
purity is about 76 percent and ehb
system after one step purification the
the purity is about 92
which is much higher and uh after two
steps of purification expression level
of this this is this best specific
antibodies or about 130
me per liter and in this hp system the
expression level is about 1.7
gram per liter after one per one step of
purification
so
here
in this case sometimes hydro purity
after purification can be achieved in
this hp system but you can always expect
a much higher expression level
here's another example of best specific
anybody
in this case the most impressive part is
that after one step of purification this
expression level which is yield can
reach 4.7
gram per liter
and this is very important because for
most specific by specific anybody's
assembly is a major issue
usually the purity is quite low after
one step of purification so multiple
step purifications often needed
but the more purification steps the more
loss of target protein
and
so usually if there are too many runs of
purification the yield is going to be
very low
but hp system can highly increase the
tatter which makes multiple step
purification easier and cheaper
take this case as example
even after three steps of purification
we can still have more than one gram per
liter yield
this is very
this is very
important because it can significantly
reduce the cost for prayer and this
study
this is another typical case
this one shows how animal fragments
liking fc regions performs irregular and
turbochill
hpr systems
according to our experience fc regions
can also enhance protein expression so
for moleculars lacking of the region
titles can be extremely low in some
cases here in this case the competitor's
uh system the expression level is
playing below larger than 100 meter per
liter
and in our trouble through hp system the
expression level is
higher than 2.5 gram per liter
in this case the title increased more
than 20 volts
and another feature of this
case is that this is also a case of bad
specific anybody anybody
for best specific antibodies
purity is also a big problem so if there
is one case for both purity and
expression level
that is going to be very hard to get
a large amount of protein with high
purity
but with this high-tech adventure of
turbulent hp system this can make a big
difference
this can also make multiple step
purification possible to get
proteins with high purity and also can
significantly reduce the cost and time
the last case of hp system is a very
extreme case here the protein is almost
undetectable in the supernatant of the
competitor system
and the yield of purification is only
one meat per liter
if this is a screen stage the candidate
should simply be discarded but if this
but if this is a must-have molecular
then hp system can help to make this job
easier in this case
the yield increased from one meat per
liter to 22 mm increased more than 20
volts
even if the tire is still low
but
this has made this impossible production
become possible
and this is not unusual for human design
proteins some unnatural proteins can be
hard to express but sometimes these
molecules are very important so
in that case you can also try hp system
to increase the tether and decrease the
cost
as i mentioned earlier in this
presentation we developed turbochill hp
system to specifically target the unmet
demands for biologics and diagnostics
development but it is not the only
system that we developed it is actually
part of a comprehensive platform in this
platform we also have turbulence t and
temperature express system
even though there are many commercial
protein expression systems at this field
we have done benchmarking with available
ones our system
outperforms them all
for turbo true hd platform there are two
major features the first one is it is
really fast from gene synthesis to
deliver can be as fast as two weeks and
you know we also have very large
capacity to enrich high variable
screening and regarding application
situations for therapeutic animal
development it is
usually used in this early stage
from discovery and target identification
screening for candidates and also lead
identification validation
for diagnostic development it is majorly
focused on this target investigation and
characterization phases
photo patrol express system it lies
between show ht and true hp system it is
faster than 2hp and
gives
a better yields than 2ht
for therapeutic antibody development it
is usually used in lead optimization in
the early stage of very clinical studies
and for diagnostics development it also
is also used in this middle part of this
development process
before we move to the final summary of
the virtual platform i just want to give
you a
database assignment to better show the
unique features of different systems and
also
for turbo tool as a whole platform
here is the overview of the capabilities
of different systems
all molecules show here the antibodies
first of all as for this hp system the
high standard can be as high as 7 gram
per liter and the average data is about
3 gram per liter and for express system
the high yields can be
higher than 2 gram per liter and the
average tatter is also very close to 1
gram per liter regarding this show ht
and the competitors comparison we have a
rooming
room in figure here as you can see here
our total hd system is also much better
than our
competitors system
and i also want to show you some typical
groups of uh antibodies
the first group is that antibodies with
with low to medium tattering competitive
system
and in archeology system it's increased
a little bit
but in the cho express system the title
can be increased to one to two gram per
liter
and there also are some antibodies that
are extremely low tattered in
competitors service system
and usually in basic in these cases we
will think
uh something might be wrong with the
sequence to influence the expression of
this antibody
but there are some there are one group
of antibodies that can that was
transferred to our turbo true
ht and express system and the title was
increased
and the title was further increased in
the express system so
if you encounter some cases like this
maybe switch to this turbocharged system
can help
but there is also another group here
the in this group uh there are many
there are some antibodies with extremely
low tattering competitor system we
switched it to our capacitor system but
it's the title was not increased
neither so
so i think there are all there are
indeed some
some some some antibodies were this
sequence
something is wrong with the sequence to
influence that the expression of
of this protein
and for turbo true system temperature hp
system there are also a typical group of
antibodies
for this
group of extremely load header
antibodies in competitive system we have
tested some in our hp system
all the
all the antibodies we tested
have
been observed
significantly increase
uh in tighter so
after the comparison we do have uh some
advices for for the truth of the choice
of different systems
first
if
if you see some medium to to load header
in competitors in your vendor's system
maybe you just need to switch to
ht or express system to
to to
to see that a very huge increase of
title and if you need ground level for
antibody or
you have observed extremely load header
in other vendor then maybe the best
choice is to switch to the hp system
this is the final summary of turbochill
platform as you can see here the
different systems of this virtual
platform was recommended by its required
amount and also the timeline for true ht
the required amount should be
upon one to five week and
the turnaround time starts from two
weeks for two express system the
required amount should be less than
point five grams and the turnaround time
starts from three weeks for true entropy
usually a larger amount of
proteins are needed usually is more than
0.5 grams and starting
turnaround time is six weeks
here this is a summary of this turbo
true platform this is a state of the art
mammalian protein production system both
from a tatter and third and turnaround
time
perspective
especially for this true hp system
we have
several very
important features which is the high
tide can be up to 7 gram per liter and
the average tire can be
3 gram per liter and we can also scale
up the production to 200 liters
and other important measures of this uh
temperature platform is that this is a
very
uh we this is a platform that has a very
comprehensive portfolio
we have this field free version and
control version and also back
installation control version
with this state-of-the-art turbo troll
product expression system and also this
comprehensive
and comprehensive portfolio we can
definitely help you almost any fields of
protein sensor researchers
as you can see here we have already
helped a lot of researchers in the
centers to achieve their goals
so
if you are interested
just don't hesitate to contact us
this is all for my presentation part
thank you all for your attention
let's move to the next section
thank you hal for your informative
presentation we have a couple of poll
questions here before we get started
with the q a
session okay let's get started
the first poll question is
where did you learn about the gen script
turbo chill platform
take a moment to submit your answer
okay
our last poll question is
which turbo chill platform are you most
interested in
take a moment to select the best option
it can be more than one
okay great we will now start the live q
a portion of the webinar
if you do have a question you'd like to
ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
okay here we go
[Music]
question number one
what is the difference between turbo
show versions
okay uh
thank you and uh
thank you for this question and uh i i
will try to answer
this question and first i think in this
presentation i i show different versions
during development process but this is
just to show that we have made some
progress
and we optimized the cell lan and vector
and also uh the culture process but
after the the release we just have one
version of uh turbocharged
but but as you can see uh in the last
slide we
we do have some different systems i have
summarized the
uh the features of different systems and
listed on the flight and uh you can also
find the information on our website so
if you're interested you can go to check
our website
thank you
okay thank you
second question will be
do you have license for cho cells
uh yes of course we we have lessons from
ececc and uh we are uh we can uh perform
uh commercial use for the cell and we
can also sub license uh some
some products from this
system
thank you
and
to that
the third question is can we license
turbo cho system
uh okay this is a very good question but
we have not considered this option yet
because
this is just released so currently the
answer is no
but if many people are interested we may
really evaluate this option in the
future
thank you
the next question is
as for the purity
how many steps are needed to hit 98
percent
okay uh uh this is a very good question
actually for for anybody usually the
pure is very high so
for some antibodies we just need one
step to get that that is 98 purity but
uh for many other i think for most of
the cases uh two-step purification will
be much safer and uh ig script if you
choose choose the true hp system i think
we have a default two-step purification
beautiful
is turbo cho ht and express a transient
expression system
uh yes the answer to this question is
yes and
uh as you can see that uh from gene
synthesis to deliver proteins we just
need two weeks for hd system and
three weeks for express systems so just
the transient expression system
okay
see
the next question is how can the turbo
chill platform assist in different
antibody drug discovery and diagnostic
stages
okay i think uh the answer to this
question is so we can assist in almost
any
phases of this diagnostic and uh and
drug discovery stages
because
for diagnosis for diagnostics there is
no gmp
requirement so
our hp system and ht and express express
system can cover almost all the demands
but for therapeutics
required for therapeutic development we
can cover all pre-clinical
demands
great
okay on to the next one can
turbo chill platform be used for
intracellular or membrane
protein production
uh uh this is very a very good question
and the answer is uh yes but i have to
say that when developing this
platform all optimizations were done
with antibodies so
uh this platform should work best for
anybody or
and maybe also secretion proteins
however i think this platform has some
features that can benefit production of
all cancer proteins i like the the
the platform has very high expression
level and it's also very resilient so i
think
definitely it can be used to express
uh
intracellular antibody intestinal
proteins and also membrane proteins
okay great
see
what antibody subtypes can gen script
turbo chill platform express
okay uh the the the answer to this
question is
i think
it is uh all isotypes
actually during during the development
uh phases we have tested nearly all
kinds of method types like
we have tried uh human antibodies like
human energy one
g4 and we also have tried the mouse igg
1 and mass ig 2a and we have also tried
rabbit rggs so
most of them performs are pretty good
the next question
can you explain how to compare the
antibody with high yield but low purity
and low
yield but high purity which is the most
important purity
or purity or yield which is the most
important
i think uh for most of the antibodies
the purity is very high so
in real world anybody's purity is
usually not a big issue
but if you did come across this this
situation i think the answer depends on
your applications for example if this is
a therapeutic
therapeutic
development so the purity is very
important but if this is just a region
for researchers only
then the yield might be the first part
already
thank you
do you have any suggestions
if the targeted mab has low
tighter in either excuse me if i
mispronounce that in
either competitor system and turbo cho
system
uh all right so
i think
uh
usually this is a
this is a very rare situation and i have
also
summarized some data
in the i think in the last two slides
there is the data summary and as you can
see that
we have uh tested many
low expression antibodies in our hp
system
we do see some some some antibodies that
have very low tether in ht or express
system but when we switched to hp system
the target increased uh significantly so
uh so i think the the first uh uh
uh so so i think first i will recommend
you to use our hp system
but if that does uh if that still does
not work
then maybe i think you should consider
to give up on this molecular because if
you uh if you move forward with this
molecular that production will be a huge
problem
next question
would turbo chill be more interesting to
express nand bodies than prokaryotic
systems
uh i think this is a very good question
but
we have not
we we have not compared this
turbochord system with paraquaratic
systems
because usually in this two system
we choose between these two systems
they're they are very different for
like e-coli systems
the cost is very low but the
the the ttm will be much different
so
uh but if you choose to express the nano
body in
uh choose system and other memory system
there will be some a ptm if that that is
necessary so so my answer will be
if you need ptm you can you you you can
choose this uh turbochill system because
it performs very good among many other
many systems but if you do not need that
you can choose like e-coli system
because the the cost is much is much
much larger
okay great
when should i choose gen script turbo
cho hp platform
okay i think uh the answer to this
question also lasts in our slides and
uh you can always choose turbo true hp
system but this system is uh
is designed for that ground level pro of
protein production it is usually used in
that pre-ind invasive uh
toxicity study in
animals and also
many
many demands for diagnostic development
and
and
in that area this is a very good system
but if you need a larger amount of
antibody or if you have experienced some
some bad experience in other systems or
with other other vendors you can always
try to
use
you can always try our hp platform which
which performs very good especially in
anybody production
thank you
and it looks like we have time for one
more question
the final question is
i am currently expressing a very
important antibody in-house
but the yield is very low
any suggestions on increasing the yield
in labs
okay so
and uh first i i just wanna uh
uh thank you for this question and then
i i i will give you uh some suggestions
based on my experience uh first i would
definitely recommend you to do a code
optimization and there are a lot of free
tools online and i we have seen a lot of
cases where uh doesn't uh where protein
doesn't express goods and
after this occurred optimization the
pattern increased a lot
and
uh
as you and as i said before you you can
send a lot of free tools online and you
can also try our code optimization tool
at g-script you can find that on our
website and uh
this will this tool is also one of the
best on the market we have a lot of
cases
and uh then after that code optimization
you can also try different
expression systems there are many pretty
good commercial systems out there if it
still doesn't work you can also this
production to us we can offer a
professional service on our
state-of-the-art
turbocharge system
thank you how very insightful answers to
those great questions
um
do you have any final comments for our
audience
[Music]
okay
thank you again hal for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor genscript for underwriting
today's educational webcast
thank you
uh just before we go here i'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we do
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time
goodbye
you